hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich befinde
mich hier gerade mitten in dortmund wir
machen gerade so ein tv-projekt das
schade am 15 november wind megacool
weswegen ich gerade öfter in dortmund
bin eigentlich jede woche drei mal und
wir haben es gerade drehschluss und ich
dachte mir das ist super cool wenn ich
meinen format was ich damals geplant
habe also ein bisschen fortsetzen wir
hatten ein paar bei mir dann ein bad in
köln zusammen mit max das hat echt spaß
gemacht und danach kamen wir dann nichts
mehr ich brauche nicht mehr so viele
videos gemacht wir sind jetzt hier in
dortmund es geht weiter hat zusammen mit
felix das ist mein dreh partner für das
tv format und der wird mir jetzt was
geiles empfehlen wo wir bestellen können
und dann freue ich mich auf das gleis zu
essen aus dortmund und danach vielleicht
auch irgendwann auch das schlechteste
das kommt dann nächste woche oder in ein
paar tagen aber erstmal geht es jetzt
natürlich immer das beste wir gehen als
rein bestellen und ja wenn ihr aus
dortmund kommt schreibt auch super gerne
in die kommentare das kennen wo und ob
ihr vielleicht was anderes empfohlen hat
wird ich bin jetzt allerdings mal
gespannt was felix mir empfiehlt und
denen er zeige ich euch mal felix hier
soweit freund hast du hunger mitgebracht
ich sag dir einzig was gut ist jeweils
leckeres mehr sonst bin ich richtig
sauer und die zuschauer erst mal weil
der felix das ist ungesund überleben
über nur gesund er gibt sich um
gesundheit geht zum lecker um geil
naja okay leute ich bin jetzt hier mit
felix quasi am set ich habe ja gerade
schon erzählt wir bringen hat hier seine
tv projekte das wird auf jeden fall
lustig startet am 15 november und dann
sind wir dann immer zu sehen und
deswegen dachte ich mir ich brauche dich
auch mal wieder für einen essens format
ich mache mich nämlich das doping zu
marie sind paar tagen da gewesen ich
mache mich nämlich aktuell auf die suche
nach youtube an in verschiedenen städten
die mit ihr einmal das beste essen
bestellen und das schlechteste du darfst
input geben was ist so das beste was man
hier bestellen kann wo du sagst das ist
so geil da habe ich schon aufgestellt
das feiert du auch das feiern die
zuschauer weiß sobald man kann natürlich
auch auf lieferanten vertrauen aber das
ist manchmal also ich habe die erfahrung
gemacht dass leute die wirklich dort
wohnen sich viel besser auskennen als
irgendwelche bewertungen von lieferanten
und du kannst dich ja auch deswegen
haben was raus wir schnell bestellen
könnt geiles essen das gute ich kenne
viele ganz oben gehen beim und ich
glaube weil da ich weiß alex gerne hier
ist keine besonders guten und ich glaube
wir das bestimmt bürgern also wobei ich
muss sagen der erste partner mit max ja
da haben wir auch bei es ging nicht nur
um berger also ist es okay und können
sich entscheiden ich will auf jeden fall
bürger sagen welche alex ist gerne
burger wir wissen und deswegen gegen den
burger eigentlich noch viele leute
positiv überrascht gewesen von football
sei inzwischen aber irgendwas sagen
geworden er dackeln bestehe aber die
haben hier in dortmund gestartet die
ermittler brückstraße ganz kleinen laden
gestalten und die liefern ihren oder
muss ich da hinten ich verwende nur da
freue ich mich als ich habe jetzt schon
darauf gewettet dass du irgendwie sowas
aus willst was du mega gesund ist weil
da gerade auf seinem gesunden trip ist
dass er aufpassen was er ist sich auch
und du kannst regensburger mit bestellen
aber ich habe auch nur einmal nein
da hat wenn er ihn nicht aufisst anstalt
in den kommentator hält gegen dich das
ist cool die haben eine eigene seite so
ist also ich kenne food brothers es ist
ja klar ich mache das schon öfter so
dass ich burger taste und ich glaube
dass ich da schon mal gegessen hat aber
ich hab's nicht gefilmt deswegen lass
das lieber machen über die
verhandlungsmacht selber anleihen die
machen das selber und ja ich habe schon
so viele burger gegessen die sind top
swing freue ich mich darauf danke der
galaxis ausgewählt hat
so pass mal auf du was möchtest du denn
für einen ich werde ganz normal dass
aber ein bisschen leid aber ich gehöre
mit pommes die ist so ähnlich wirklich
genau ja gut aber ich würde gerne mal
den zuschauern wir zeigen fb spezial das
augenblick so die performance hat das
gemacht für die bürger liegen machen das
war ja sowieso was ist harmlos ja viel
chili ist aber dass man chili mal und
ist jedoch ähnlich oder und ich würde
gerne hier
ja schwierig schnell auf den burger menü
genießen nämlich mit catcher bitte und
ach und ganz wichtig wenn ihm die
süßkartoffel kommt es dazu damit wir
beide haben leute die haben viele andere
bürger ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
werbung aber ich muss sagen der bürger
wird glaube ich echt gut ich hoffe auch
beim liefern sich mit gibt es doch den
double bacon schießt und in latsch obama
sind hatte ich ja was auch wissen ja und
was ganz wichtig ist schreibt mal
weitere youtuber die irgendwo wohnen in
die kommentare ich kenne ja eigentlich
so gut wie jeden und dann fahre ich da
mal hin und bestellen mit denen auch das
beste in der innenstadt berlin muss ich
als nächstes hin dass mein nächstes ziel
mal gucken vielleicht gibt es ja noch
bessere sachen ich habe schon gestellt
ich habe mich für timo so komme was
ankommt das ist irgendwie lustig weil
die finden alle nicht dein büro der
alles sehr versteckt okay da kam mit
einem auto mit dem es war das habe ich
noch gar nicht gesagt gekostet hat das
27 eur 50 plus 2 euro trinkgeld und das
kann man ja nicht berechnet also 13 eur
25 75 pro bürger pro bürger menü ist
nicht ganz günstig aber noch immer leute
schaut hier mal rein kann man das sehen
ich habe wirklich jetzt über eine woche
brach ich habe wirklich über eine woche
keinen gegessen und das sieht einfach
wild aus alter felix warte ich musste
einmal einstellen in die tüte schon mal
so der erste eindruck wir filmen wie
rain oh mein gott gebt euch dass es ist
ein paar junge felix alltag
möchte die kohle aber ständig nicht mehr
wir haben ja einmal die saucen echt 13
eigentlich habe ich nur zwei bestellt
dann könnte dann kommen eine tonne und
dann haben wir hier die burger alter war
da noch mal eins das ist würde ich sagen
deine und das hier müsste dann meiner
sein
warum sollte ich nein eigentlich nicht
noch du kannst du auch auf einen burger
nicht in salat und gurke unternehmen und
die tomaten kommen wir das mal
mutter wirklich ja jetzt nicht mehr zu
helfen
[Musik]
lasst mich erstmal mit dem kommissar
anfang wirkt sich auch auf die
süßkartoffel wie ein x bow süßkartoffel
pommes mit ketchup
waren wir ja ich hab ich habe dir
eigentlich gar nicht bestellt aber der
mir trotzdem auf deren basis
mitgeliefert ich glaube ich muss mal ist
eine super auch noch warm ist
[Musik]
kommt einer geht noch felix kommenden
ein bis noch felix guck mal hier das ist
wirklich da hast du heute einen richtig
guten namen ausgesucht ich hatte nämlich
im hintergrund auf dem auf dem fleisch
ich hatte ich hatte im hinterhof das ist
die hier gibt aber ich wusste nicht mehr
genau wo und dass die hierhin liefern
aber ich hab' mich sagen preis
gerechtfertigt auf jeden fall ne also
bei diesem bürger stimmt wirklich fast
alles ich will nicht sagen das ist ein
10 10 ist das nicht ich habe auch schon
besser begriffen aber wo bin ich von der
stockholm münchen den stockholmer
barrels das ist der beste laden den ich
je war und da würde ich auch unbedingt
noch mal hingehen und ein video drehen
weil das ist wirklich erstaunlich wie
weit kommt man sehr schön bist du dabei
wenn wir in bergen norwegen anderen
sachen leute so sieht das aus
er war also meine meinung dazu ist
natürlich wenn du in den richtig guten
burger laden ist und dort vor ort ist
ist es noch mal eine schippe besser aber
wenn es ein guter bergers mit guten
zutaten dann kann der auch geliefert
werden und es trotzdem total geil so wie
dieser hier wie die fette coolen köln es
gibt noch andere läden und köln
bestellen können weil jetzt die zusage
einfach so gut sind habe halten können
wir ja gewohnt ist weiß das und dieser
hier ist ähnlich super burger war
einfach so und das macht mir spaß macht
und weil man bei 8000 dann
machen wir einen chip day ein tag so
viele kalorien wie geht wir beide gegen
dann natürlich wenn es doch einfach
machen wir das und ich hab immer wenn
ich so festtage habt
nein nein und ich glaub nicht aber lasst
uns bitte sagen bei 5000 leute bei 5.000
bikes machen wir einen tag bei 7,77
machen wir einen tag 14.000 kalorien wir
beide zusammen ich hoffe dass dann
vielleicht muss man ihm haben schaffen
ja okay das total gern nach oben da
abonniert den kanal für weitere es ins
videos bald kommt auch noch das
schlechteste restaurant hier in dortmund
da freue ich mich auch drauf und ich bin
gespannt wohin fahren soll leute dann
bist du schon haut rein zu vertrauen
[Musik]